they're coming after the king again bro
again they coming after the
[ __ ] king
rogan uh did a
conversation he had a conversation with
josh zepps you guys know josh's episode
i don't know him i just know this
conversation right and he was uh he was
a journalist he used to write for the
huffington post
i think uh i guess and then he went and
moved back to australia and then he
started working for abc which is i think
uh australian broadcasting uh
corporation or something like that and i
think he's been on rogan a bunch of
times and they had a discussion on
whether the vaccine uh causes
myocardosis
carditis yeah and um basically rogan
would say yo the vaccine is causing
myocarditis you know we shouldn't be
giving this thing to people this is
[ __ ] up etc and then he was like well
kovid also causes it and causes it even
more at a higher rate at a higher rate
and i think myocardia is essentially
like an uh an inflamed partner
yeah and people are really concerned
because there's been uh larger than
average number of soccer players that
have been developing these heart
problems and yeah it happens i think in
males between a certain age i want to
say 12 and 17 but typically males like
so if you're looking out for your male
listeners right that's a thing 100
so
uh obviously people are going to put
things together you know you're like oh
[ __ ] all these soccer players got
vaccinated now they dropping like flies
it's the vaccine that's taking them down
but it could also be coveted causing
some myocarditis or it could have
nothing to do with it etc so the guy
proves rogan wrong rogan i think was
very graceful on twitter about it and he
was like yo if i'm going to be made to
look done by anybody i'm glad it's my
friend josh zepps i love him he's
awesome and in the clip he's like oh i
thought i've read another study that he
does post but he's like i thought i read
another study that said that's not the
case but he he's like okay he's willing
to admit the podcast all right i might
be wrong he doesn't like argue he
doesn't shout him down he's okay fair
enough causes a big stir
yeah internet goes wild um and then all
of a sudden these
these people come together and i say
people because everybody's listing them
as doctors but it turns out not all of
them are even doctors 270 different
scientists doctors doctors scientists
health professionals has all turned into
270 doctors yeah and they're not even
like phds no some people just have
doctorates somebody cleans the [ __ ]
hospital right it's just 270 random
people that are coming together and be
like hey spotify you need to do
something
and then they don't say what they want
them to do oh no they do they don't they
don't
well say say what do they ask they want
some kind of policy against not against
it just notifies people of
misinformation
so they don't tell them what to do
that seems like a pretty reasonable
thing though it doesn't seem like the
craziest like
i think they
people here's what i think i think
that's not the craziest ask
i think some of the stuff they say like
his beliefs are dangerous or whatever
that's too much i think it's crazy to
say hey we don't want taking off spotify
just notify people when there could be
misinformation have a policy in place
who decides what information is true
it's about if i would have to lean on
their own people and i guess that could
be messy there's a lot of gray area
there i don't necessarily have a problem
with that what's weird to me is
everybody jumping on rogan and now he
has kind of come to represent the right
wing
he's the new trump bro
the corporate the corporate media needs
someone to ship yes and that's what's
crazy because if he's your right
right-wing trump guy he endorsed bernie
to win like i want bernie to win in
2020. in that podcast he's talking to
the josh guy yeah and he's having like a
very liberal approach like how to help
cities he's like yo we have all this
money to spend on wars abroad why are we
spending that money to like help these
little cities that are dealing with
increased like crime and like
homelessness like where's all this money
that we can invest in them very little
that's a super liberal point you're not
saying he's the new trump literally
you're saying no they're treating them
right yeah they're acting like they're
the same person he said positioning i'm
sorry and positioning specifically on
the right because that's what the left
needs to do yes if they're like hey this
guy's reasonable he's in the middle then
there's nothing to push back they have
to push the right as dangerous yeah
because they are incompetent on the left
you know what i mean yeah and i'm not
saying there's no dangerous people in
the right but joe ain't right he said
that he said barack obama is the best
president i've seen in my lifetime and
he wants michelle obama to run and hope
she wins in 2024. so what about this guy
is so right-wing and and i'm sure he's
also got conservative beliefs as well
that's like every [ __ ] human being
right so it's like but the thing that's
interesting about this is i think this
is all corporate meteor uh corbett media
uh hit piece
and i think that they
have to make him radioactive because
they're not really asking for anything
like if you look at those doctors like
why aren't those doctors asking the same
thing from cnn and fox news yeah like
why don't you ask cnn and fox news to
talk about the information they're
putting out there yeah because a lot of
that [ __ ] ends up being uh
misinformation or fake or we didn't get
it right and we didn't know exactly what
these things were
joe is literally interviewing people who
he believes have interesting things to
say on the podcast those people say
those things he can't control what those
people said yeah like now great did he
control them coming on his platform or
not but who does he call he calls those
370 doctors first and goes hey can i
have this person come on the podcast
and he talks for 16 hours a week he's
gonna get some [ __ ] wrong
yeah it's amazing every [ __ ] loser
has a podcast but none of you give any
grace to the guy who podcasts at the
highest level and does the most hours of
any person who gets the [ __ ] wrong
that's that's why i think this is a hit
piece because you're not keeping that
same energy with the news 100 is a hit
piece i agree with you right completely
so it's like who's really behind it who
benefits the most from this and i think
it's okay to be wrong but we all kind of
conveniently forget that they were
telling us early on mass don't help and
now it's mass mass mass double mass
triple mask fine uh it's okay to be
wrong yeah but if rogan is wrong it
can't be [ __ ] he's the devil he's all
that's wrong in the world the news got
the [ __ ] wrong fauci got the [ __ ] wrong
so people get [ __ ] wrong that's okay he
actually very quickly was like oh maybe
i'm wrong within the same [ __ ] video
clip you play he admits i might be wrong
like the news didn't do that for weeks
yeah we're walking around without mass
early in coven because they don't help
only n95 helps now all of them help now
we're two now we're three
it's like y'all are getting [ __ ] wrong
we're all learning about this stuff he
gonna do the same thing but he's not a
scientist he's a guy he's a stand-up
comic with a platform yeah that's it
yeah it's it's tricky man it's really
annoying
and i imagine that it's so funny because
if they got him kicked off spotify which
is not what they're asking they're
asking for them to i guess have some
sort of policy that lets you know if
it's misinformation yeah which is very
tricky because the people in control of
that policy literally control truth and
that is a very dicey thing especially on
a conversation platform yeah i mean like
like rogan brought up an article like a
study that more or less kind of points
to what he was saying yeah and there's
conflicting studies like there is with
science in general yeah so he brought up
his study and someone else brought up a
different study and like it's not for
them necessarily to figure it out but
have a conversation i don't see it as
dangerous you know this whole thing
about like trust the science is just so
funny because like
like my mom went into a doctor once and
said the doctor said you'll never be
able to have kids you have a thyroid
issue right she didn't trust the science
she got a second opinion and the second
pain was like no just take these pills
you'll be able to have kids everything's
fine and now we're bored my mom had a
doctor tell her she needed a
hysterectomy
she didn't need one at all she's about
to get her if you just trust the science
on one guy
a doctor
same kind of [ __ ] that'll write
this letter i'm gonna get my as a woman
i would get my entire uterus taken out
when i didn't have to she was fine
a [ __ ] hysterectomy is crazy hey you
can't have kids crazy
yeah you can't just blindly trust
everything science says because science
gets [ __ ] wrong you should question it i
think pushing back completely and saying
oh science is all [ __ ] cause they
got one thing wrong is also crazy but
it's okay to be a little bit questioning
and saying i don't know about this yeah
science says some of us will like lose
our hair and we haven't done that you
know i mean a lot of people in here
still got their hair yeah and that's
science yeah and it looks beautiful
hair looks absolutely gorgeous
wait why are you bringing that up do we
even keep sat or something like that no
i don't know yeah
that'd be a good segment
okay well done no but yeah go out i
think this is a good example of just how
we all live in our bubbles yeah because
he found uh joe rogan found information
that
supported his his belief yeah and then
the doctor or whoever that guy was on
malone malone he comes on with
information that supports his beliefs
and it's like
you you can pull up both articles and
yeah both say different things so maybe
maybe this is like a reason why we
shouldn't immediately trust the science
dude science constantly disagrees with
you and maybe this is why we need to
have
many more conversations and listen to
many conversations before we decide to
have one opinion the problem is that
human nature we're not looking for
information we're looking for
confirmation but maybe that's something
we have to unlearn right so instead of
going hey let's curate every bit of
information for all human beings so they
can all think the same way about
something maybe we should start saying
hey go out there and read a bunch of
[ __ ] listen to a bunch of [ __ ]
experience a bunch of [ __ ] don't let one
guy tell you everything about the world
the the only thing i would push back is
like i do trust the science just in
terms of science is about running
experiments and figuring [ __ ] out so
it's like we run an experiment we figure
something out and then oh someone runs
another experiment and disproves that so
like science is
that study where you keep learning and
things do change and i think that's what
we agree with i think we have an issue
with people
a who blindly disagree with everything
science says because it doesn't fit
their idea ideals or people who blindly
agree with everything science says no
matter how much it changes
i mean can we just acknowledge like
there are [ __ ] out there that
have had
two
vaccine shots yeah a booster yeah i
think in israel they got four
and the study just came out that that
fourth one isn't that great and
still get the virus yeah and they call
people who are skeptical of the vaccine
stupid
yeah
hello yeah i mean
bare minimum you could go all right
maybe you're not stupid it's not at this
point you get four shots and you still
get the [ __ ] are you calling the guy who
didn't get it stupid yeah that's a
little bit crazy right you're you're the
ignorant one you're the one setting the
country like i think the vaccine overall
is a good thing i don't blindly i'm not
getting a booster yet
you know what i mean i'm waiting i'm
like just wait [ __ ] science is
constantly disproving yourself
but really i got it i got it i just want
to point out
that felt weird bro very submissive
i almost spit it out the second mark
said swallowing i almost spit that [ __ ]
out bro what are you doing damn
daddy dude
i'm glad i hesitated because if he said
i was like
that would have been super uncomfortable
mark's like act like a pastor and spit
it out
around my face
um
yeah my boys it's a tricky one man it's
a tricky one i hope we get to a point
where we could actually listen to people
and don't get me wrong the people that
refuse to take the vaccine are also
annoying as [ __ ] yeah right like the
super anti-vaxxers just like the super
trusted science people you're equally
[ __ ] the same person yeah you are
exactly the same person
and you're both really [ __ ] hipsters
when you think about it yeah right like
you're both trying to uh reject what you
believe to be the common culture right
right you're both pushing back against
something and then you find yourself
virtuous because of it you're both
[ __ ] annoying but there are people
that operate in this middle ground where
like yeah we got the vaccine because it
was easy for our lives but at the same
time we're like man i'm kind of dumb
getting vaccines bro
unless y'all figure some [ __ ] out we're
not gonna worry about it ever again like
remember when we got back when we were
younger and i don't gotta worry about
that [ __ ] i ain't got rickets since
right never got like spades or what's
the other one oh yo [ __ ] smallpox
smallpox polio isn't there another one
shingles measles mumps rubella yeah you
ain't got nothing rubella i don't even
know rubella
mine is rubella i thought that was the
green [ __ ] they put in salads yeah
that's arugula
yeah yeah yeah point is is uh i think we
just i think it's okay to be a little
skeptical now
and go watch you just call it a covet
shot like a flu shot we're like i a lot
of times it don't work but it could help
so get it it's a coveted shot it's not a
vaccine it's a shot yeah if you get it
it'll be mild it's the covered mids
you know what i'm saying like it's not
all the way yeah it's not all the way
like you're not gonna wear it proudly
but like you need a sneaker to do some
yard work
yeah man you're gonna get yourself a
nice little cove admit
you